jérôme marty médecin généraliste
président de l'union française pour une
médecine libre bonsoir jérôme mary merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france tout d'abord votre opinion sur
cette deuxième vague qu'on semble
maintenant nous présenter comme quasi
inéluctable en tout cas pour l'automne
écoutez je crois que rien inéluctable
personne n'est sûr de rien ce qu'on sait
c'est que le virus est parmi nous que le
virus circule pour l'instant ils ne
trouvent pas de solution pour tout d'un
coup donné de gros cluster comme cela
s'est produit il ya quelques semaines
nous sommes en fait revenu dans la
situation de novembre et décembre avec
un virus qui etc et sans qui contaminent
des jeunes des actifs qui font des
formes peu aussi symptomatique ou
asymptomatiques
mais il ne contamine pas fort
heureusement de patients âgés et à
risque parce que les mesures barrières
sont prises en particulier dans les
ehpad en particulier dans les hôpitaux
en particulier dans les foyers de
personnes âgées et dans les grands
magasins dans les lieux confinés les
gens portent des masques c'est ce qu'il
faut faire et puis forte heureusement
grâce à la saison dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons les gens sont dehors et on
sait qu'il ya moins de risque en plein
air pour une diffusion de masse de ce
virus
si je vous comprends bien ça veut dire
selon l'ong le virus n'est pas
spécialement moins virulent qui n'est
pas parti comme le prédisait le
professeur out à l'époque avec la saison
mais tout simplement voilà is here que
là bas bruit parce que il ya ces gestes
barrière c'est ce que vous nous
expliquer ce qu'on a appris avec avec
avec cette affection qu on a appris à
connaître puisqu'il encore il ya quatre
c'est moi le savait rien ce qu'on a
appris c'est que c'est une infection qui
se développe en les murs c'est à dire
c'est pas tellement il a fait sur une
affection qui va se développer à
l'extérieur tous les clusters tous les
points de départ important de cette
épidémie se sont produits dans des zones
confinées
donc ce sont ceux sommes dès l'instant
où l'on porte les masques et où l'on
sait où le roux lens où on respecte les
gestes barrière ou aux nerfs ou à l'air
et les pièces en outre les fenêtres
il ya moins de risques diffusion et puis
comme mieux encore une fois les gens
respectent quand même en grande partie
les mesures barrières le virus ne trouve
pas de solution pour se développer mais
par contre ils continuent à bas bruit
à circuler et à contaminer mais
principalement des gens jeunes donc il
est parmi nous ils ne diffusent pas de
façon grave
maintenant quand la saison froide va
arriver quand il quand les gens vont
rentrer et si en plus ils ont une
certaine lassitude quant au respect des
gestes-barrières là viendra le danger
alors justement les scènes qu'on a vu à
paris le jour de la fête de la musique
ces jeunes agglutinés en dansant son
masque ça veut dire quoi selon vous
voulez craignent et ses conséquences
dans quinze jours oui écoutez c'est une
sorte de bêta test c'est une sorte de
test grandeur nature est important par
rapport à la capacité de ce virus a
diffusé on va voir d'ici 14 15 jours
s'il y a des conséquences
il faut espérer que non parce qu'encore
une fois c'était à l'extérieur
maintenant on sait que ce virus diffuse
par contact proche et prolongé
on sait que lorsque l'on chante ou que
l'on hurle on aérosols is beaucoup donc
s'il y avait au milieu de cette foule
des gens qui sont porteurs du virus
ils peuvent avoir contaminé d'autres
personnes c'est une évidence des
responsabilités de grands sportifs par
exemple un novak djokovic qui d'ailleurs
dit regretter profondément d'avoir
organisé ce fameux tournoi djokovic
testé positif ça veut dire selon vous
qu'il ya une forme de relâchement tout
de même dans les dents les esprits
aujourd'hui l'épidémie semble loin dans
la tête de la plupart des gens écoutez
c'est difficile de respecter ces fameux
gestes-barrières de changer nos vies
pendant des semaines et des semaines et
des semaines et donc donne des moments
comme ça festifs comme la fête de la
musique on ne peut voir un certain
relâchement maintenant ce que l'on doit
observer c'est que dans les grands
magasins dans les hôpitaux dans les
ehpad dans d'autres lieux
on doit reconnaître que les gestes
barrières sont respectés maintenant des
transports en commun aussi mais ce sont
des lieux où souvent le port du masque
est obligatoire peut-être faut-il garder
cette obligation pour un certain nombre
de lieux et puis je rejoins mon confrère
qui était sur votre antenne juste juste
avant moi il faut surtout tester tester
tester testé massivement souvent
aléatoirement pour savoir comment se
servir y circulent
à quel taux afin de savoir si oui ou non
il y à une augmentation de sa
propagation
on a beaucoup louent l allemagne 1 pour
sa bonne gestion de la crise aujourd'hui
l'allemagne reconfirme alors localement
quelle est votre réaction ça inquiète
s'est inquièté puis mais ça nous donne
aussi un petit peu une vision de ce que
pouvait être notre avenir proche ce qui
est évident c'est que l'on ne pourra pas
reconfirmé de façon générale il faut pas
oublier que on a confiné comme ça sans
distinction tous les territoires alors
qu'il y avait des territoires où le
virus circule et très peu on a confiné
toutes les générations alors que l'on
sait que c'est principalement les
générations plus âgées qui sont à risque
parce que nous ne disposions pas de
masque parce que nous disposions pas de
test et parce que nous ne l'avions pas
l'expérience de l' usage de ces moyens
là maintenant nous avons été en quelque
sorte forme et nous sommes plus aguerris
et nous disposons des matériels
à partir de là si l'on doit encore filer
parce que le virus circule davantage sur
certains territoires
cela devra se faire de façon partielle
mais il est probable que nous n'y
échapperons pas si le virus venait à
augmenter dans sa diffusion
merci jérôme marty d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france